bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce petit cours on continue notre
fil rouge de cours sur la paléontologie
avec une perspective africaine comme je
la donne à chacun de mes de mes cours
avec aujourd'hui je pense le cours qui
est le moins paléontologique et le plus
histoire des sciences
c'est à dire aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
un cours d'histoire des sciences mais
avec une perspective sud-africaine assez
particulière donc ça va pas forcément
intéresser tout le monde mais en gros
faut que je donne un petit peu de
contexte derrière ce qui est dans ce
court donc l'afrique du sud comme tout
le monde le sait c'est un pays qui
ressort de l'apartheid
c'était en 1994 donc ça fait à peine une
génération qu'on en est sorti
c'est un pays qui est donc essaye un peu
de de retrouver ses racines on va dire
d'un point de vue social c'est un pays
qui du coup est à la recherche en fait
d'une réécriture de son histoire et vous
allez me dire réécrire l'histoire c'est
pas exactement quelque chose qui se fait
facilement en particulier quand on parle
de paléontologie mais il est vrai que
les universités insiste pour qu'on alors
ils utilisent le mot décoloniser donc
ils veulent condé colonise nos cours et
je c'est un mot que je comprends pas
trop le mot des colonisés dans le sens
où je dire de l'amérique du nord enfin
les états unis sont un pays qui est
techniquement des colonisés mais c'est
toujours des c'est toujours des blancs
capitaliste au pouvoir quoi je ne dirais
pas les indiens d'amérique qui sont au
pouvoir aux états unis donc il a beau et
décoloniser ça change pas grand chose
donc moi je préfère le mot africanisé
éventuellement la la c'est un mot que je
comprends donc voilà j'essaye
d'africaniser mes courses qui pour eux
en revient à décoloniser mes cours mais
peu importe
en tout cas joueurs en ligne avec
justement cette ligne directive que
l'université impose à nos cours j'essaye
d'africaniser mais courait alors pour ça
vous avez pu voir dans mes cours
d'évolution de paléontologie des
vertébrés que j'essaye au mieux
d'illustrer mes cours avec des fossiles
africains et voire même sud africains et
avec aussi cette cette idée de ba de
parler un peu plus des chercheurs
africains et sud africains que de parler
des chercheurs
européens et nord américains il y à
aussi puis de toute façon comme je les
dis dans mes cours précédent tous les
livres de cours
absolument tous les livres de cours de
paléontologie sont écrits par des
chercheurs qui viennent de la
civilisation occidentale est en quelque
sorte l'afrique du sud est aussi un pays
de la civilisation occidentale
majoritairement donc
donc on va pas trop pouvoir y couper
mais voilà au moins on prend une
perspective qui est un peu différente
pour arriver aussi à captiver les
étudiants parce que les étudiants ils
sont aussi bercé de ça et ça faut pas
perdre de vue le but du jeu c'est aussi
de de transmettre un message aux
étudiants
et si vous transmettez des cours qui
sont exactement les mêmes qu'en amérique
du nord ou en europe et que vous parlez
de fossiles qu'ils auront aucune chance
de voir balles et les étudiants sont
forcément beaucoup moins intéressé donc
du coup le court que je vais vous donner
aujourd'hui et bien c'est un cours qui
est sensé de sa servir d'introduction à
tous les autres et quand je dis tous les
autres c'est n'importe lesquels à un
niveau première année niveau 3e année
niveau honors n'importe quel niveau
c'est un cours qui est censé en fait
montrer aux étudiants qu'on peut changer
alors en anglais et 10 102 narrative
qu'on peut changer l'histoire mais pas
dans le sens où on va réécrire
l'histoire mais dans le sens où on va
changer notre point de vue sur
l'histoire
voilà donc le but c'est pas de changer
l'histoire elle-même réécrire l'histoire
c'est un truc de gouvernements
totalitaires ça c'est pas c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe
on ne réécrit pas l'histoire par contre
on garde la même histoire mais on change
le point de vue et au lieu de prendre
notre point de vue occidental au centre
et est bon on va changer ce point de vue
on va prendre le point de vue africain
et essayer de voir un petit peu bac
pendant que la paléontologie se
développer en europe
qu'est ce qui se passait pendant ce
temps là en afrique et voire même avant
et on va notamment ici parler de
l'histoire de la paléontologie avant la
colonisation et ça c'est un truc auquel
auquel je tiens vraiment c'est montrer
aux étudiants que l'avait pas la
paléontologie ne commence pas au moment
où le mot paléontologie a été inventé la
paléontologie c c'est une science c'est
un état d'esprit une philosophie c'est
une façon d'envisager le monde et
notamment certains types de roches qu'on
appelle
fossiles c'est une façon d'envisager les
fossiles qui est différente de
simplement les considérer comme des
cailloux
voilà des cailloux qui n'ont aucune
histoire qui ne raconte rien voilà et ça
ça marche en europe 1 je veux dire il ya
une histoire des sciences si vous
regardez l'histoire de la paléontologie
avant la paléontologie en europe vous
allez avoir des grands noms comme
léonard de vinci qui vont forcément
venir sur la table roberte pelote
bref tout un tas de choses qui ont pu
être faits et vous avez le bouquin de la
dryade mayor qui s'appelle the first
foster's dont le titre de secours est
largement inspiré un donc les premiers
chasseurs de fossiles en amérique du
nord vous avez aussi un autre livre
d'adrienne mayor qui s'appelle
américaine fassoles legends
je crois donc les légendes fossiles les
légendes de baser sur les fossiles des
amérindiens donc où la lll parle de la
paléontologie telle qu'elle était
pratiquée par les amérindiens est
certain qu'ils appelaient pas ça de la
paléontologie et ça n'avait pas un but
scientifique on est bien d'accord mais
c'était une interprétation des fossiles
qu'ils avaient qui était propre à eux et
qui souvent étaient scientifique enfin
scientifiquement juste aux sciences au
sens de la science des de l'occident
voilà donc il ya c'était donc il ya
cette idée d'africaniser le court il ya
cette idée aussi que de toute façon la
science est occidental donc on peut pas
vraiment faire autrement que d'accepter
la science occidentale telle qu'elle est
donc on ne peut pas faire autrement que
juste changer le point de vue est là ce
que je vais vous proposer aujourd'hui
c'est un changement de point de vue on
va prendre un changement on va prendre
un point de vue qui sera qui sera
purement africain et vous allez voir
quand fait eh ben on va on va arriver
quand même à picorer des idées par ci
par là des idées qui sont qui ont
finalement un sens aussi même en europe
c'est aussi ça l'intérêt du changement
de point de vue c'est que ça permet
aussi d'avoir un autre point de vue sur
soi bref alors les premiers chasseurs de
fossiles africains donc déjà commencé
par rappeler aux étudiants en quoi c'est
important les fossiles parce que en
afrique du sud il ya une grosse idée qui
règne
ici en afrique du sud notamment parmi la
jeune génération qui est que l'afrique
du sud c'est un pays pourri le
gouvernement est corrompu il ya de la
sécurité partout on a des sécheresses en
avant bref les sud africains
généralement quand ils atteignent le
niveau honors voire même le niveau
master ils ne rêvent que d'une chose
c'est de se barrer et du coup le lit des
deux déjà de cette première diapos c'est
de leur rappeler que quand le monde
entend parler de l'afrique du sud
c'est pas pour la corruption c'est pas
pour là c'est pas pour l'insécurité
c'est pas pour les sécheresses quand le
monde entend parler de l'afrique du sud
très souvent très souvent pas tout le
temps évidemment hélas mais très souvent
c'est pour les découvertes de fossiles
exceptionnels et notamment on entend
parler de johannesbourg puisque c'est à
johannesbourg que la plupart de ces
fonds découvertes de fossiles sont
faites
enfin côté de johannesbourg au cradle of
humankind donc quand on entend parler
dans la presse internationale de
l'afrique du sud c'est bien souvent pour
ses découvertes paléontologiques vous
avez ici par exemple un journal japonais
qui parle de au monal ai dit vous avez
un journal russe un journal français qui
parle aussi de mona est dit et vous avez
même au monal eddy qui figurent dans le
top 20 des plus grosses découvertes
scientifiques du siècle donc quand même
c'est pas rien donc rhône aux monnaies
les dix top 20 des plus gros des plus
grosses découvertes scientifiques du
siècle c'est-à-dire l'est pas pas
seulement les découvertes les
découvertes paléontologiques non dans
les toutes les découvertes scientifiques
confondues donc quand même c'est pas
rien c'est pas rien du tout donc c'est
ça touche partout dans le monde
ça touche toutes les strates sociales
bref c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
important la paléontologie la
paléontologie c'est en quelque sorte une
c'est comme une ambassade voilà c'est
une ambassade et donc effectivement les
gens entendent parler quand vous êtes à
l'extérieur de l'afrique du sud vous
allez entendre parler quand il est en
sécurité quand il ya des émeutes mais
vous avez aussi entendre parler de nos
découvertes paléontologiques donc et ça
et ça ça forme justement une forme de
ces la représentation que l'afrique du
sud a dans le monde
voilà comment le monde perçoit l'afrique
du sud l'afrique du sud
c'est le parc kruger c'est le tourisme
c'est la nature c'est un peu beaucoup la
sécurité à johannesbourg mais c'est
aussi et surtout de la paléontologie
voilà donc et donc à une longue histoire
de la paléontologie en afrique du sud
avec des grands noms de la paléontologie
vous avez donc raymond d'arte
découvreurs enfin qui a été décrit
l'enfant de tongs qu'il tient dans les
mains de fée blonde art c'est la photo
du milieu qui a décrit l'enfant de tang
qui est l'enfant de tang qui est le
premier australopithèques qui a été
découvert dans que c'est vraiment le
fossile j'ai presque envie de dire le
plus important du monde le premier
australopithèques donc c'était en 1924
bien avant lui si vous avez le docteur
et n'a plus mme stead qui était qui a
vraiment qui est la mère fondatrice de
la paléobotanique en afrique du sud
vous avez box brainbug brain qui a été
donc il ya travaillé à soir quand ça a
vraiment été le l'inventeur presque de
la taphonomie aussi donc chercheurs
sud-africains et vous avez leur papa a
tous envie de dire robert de broom qui a
touché à tout qui qui a découvert des
centaines et des centaines de nouvelles
espèces aussi bien dans le karoo donc
des espèces du permien trias que dans la
queue dans le crado love you man cannes
qui l'a découvert mi6 place notamment le
premier australopithèques adultes encore
une fois bien avant que l'uci soit
découverte
il a quasiment inventé le concept de
reptiles malien avec avec coop le fameux
chercheurs dans américains dont qu'il a
co inventeur on va dire du concept de
reptiles malien
donc bref vous avez ces grands noms de
la paléontologie sud-africaine qui
flotte dans l'air alors vous les avez
peut-être entendu ou les avez peut-être
pas entendu vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de tobias aussi tobias qui est le
la personne qui a décrit homo habilis
donc aussi un chercheur sud-africain
même si homo habilis a été découvert en
afrique de l'est c'est lui qui l'a
décrit le premier voilà vous avez des
grands noms et des grandes contributions
qui ont été faites par des chercheurs
sud africains à la paléontologie
mondiale et le plus alors j'ai envie
dire le plus prolifique d'entre tous est
pourtant le probablement l'un des moins
connus c'est james kitching james
kitchen qui a qui est responsable de la
quasi totalité de avec roberts broom
robert brout mais james kitching
ensemble ont découvert la quasi totalité
de ce que vous pouvez connaître en
termes de reptiles main malien voilà
donc les thérapies ciblées fameux thé
rapide vous prenez les recherches de
james key jing vous prenez les
recherches de robert braun vous couvrez
90% de tous les reptiles maliens qui ont
pu être découverts
voilà donc c'est un des plus grands
contributeurs de la paléontologie sud
africaine
l'un des moins connus aussi faut dire
que james kitching il a vraiment
commencé tout en bas de l'échelle voyez
c'est pas quelqu'un qui sait pas
quelqu'un qui a été parachuté professeur
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a commencé
tout en bas de l'échelle en tant que
technicien qui a passé qui à force de
travailler dans le terrain c'est fait
c'est fait accorder un doctorat et qui a
ensuite continué à gravir les échelons
jusqu'à devenir le chef du département
dans lequel je travaille aujourd'hui
alors il est plus chef de département
puisqu'il est mort en 2003 mais il est
devenu le chef du département où j'ai
travaillé aujourd'hui alors qu'il avait
commencé vraiment en tant que technicien
à la base donc c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui a construit sa carrière à la force
de ses jambes pas tellement la force de
ses poings à la force de ses jambes
parce qu'il a fait des kilomètres dans
le karoo
pour ainsi dire il en a fait du
kilomètre dans le cas où il en a
enquillé du kilomètre donc et il en a
remué de la terre pour en arriver là
donc
et si vous allez sur la page wikipedia
de james kitching il a écrit la phrase
que james teaching a probablement été ni
plus ni moins que le plus grands
chercheurs de fossiles au monde donc ça
quand même c'est pas rien voilà c'est
écrit là c'est wikipédia qui lie la page
wikipedia dit c'est l'un des plus grands
chercheurs de fossiles du monde
c'était un chercheur de c'était un
chercheur de fossiles extrêmement
talentueux james keach ennemis mais là
où je veux en venir moi aujourd'hui
c'est pas parler justement de ces grands
noms de la paléontologie alors que le
mot paléontologie avait déjà été
inventée non moi ce que je veux c'est
remonter encore plus loin justement
changer de perspective quitter le monde
de la paléontologie occidentale même si
elle est sud-africaine et revenir encore
plus loin donc si on remonte encore plus
loin le premier fossile qui a été qui a
été rapportée on va dire dont
l'existence a été rapporté il a été
découvert dès la fondation en fait de la
de la colonie du cap donc en 1647
il ya un bateau qui s'appelle le harlem
qui s'échoue dans la baie de la montagne
de la table donc dans la baie du cap et
cet essai c'est ça en fait l'événement
fondateur de la colonie du cap
donc c'était un bateau c'était un bateau
néerlandais et ses salles événement
fondateur de la colonie du cap puisque
sur place en fait les passagers du
harlem vous commencé à creuser des puits
vont installer une colonie vont être
secourues bien des années après et donc
en 1652 seulement de l'existence de
cette petite colonie va être reconnu et
va être nommé le cap
voilà donc c'est là c'est l'événement
fondateur on va dire de la colonie du
cap en afrique du sud
la la le naufrage du harlem en 1647 est
donc en 1652
un savant parce qu'à l'époque on disait
pas chercheurs savants non mais ont dû
ce public en fait pendant 2 quand ils
ont en fait creuser ce puits à la
recherche d'eau eh bien ils ont trouvé
des fossiles les les naufragés ont
trouvé des fossiles et donc on du ce est
le premier à décrire en fait ces
fossiles et le premier même à décrire la
coupes stratigraphiques qui a été exposé
pendant le creuset de 7,2 ce puits donc
ça c'est le premier fossile on va dire
reporter dans la littérature mais
toujours dans la littérature occidentale
toujours on est toujours dans la
littérature occidentale il faut remonter
encore plus loin et jeu on peut remonter
aussi loin qu'on puisse remonter à
savoir jusqu à l'origine d'homo sapiens
homo sapiens je le rappelle est
originaire d'afrique donc on peut se
poser la question mais du coup est ce
que les premiers homo sapiens était
capable de trouver des fossiles en fait
est déjà la première question c'est de
savoir jusqu'à ou remonte homo sapiens
lui même en afrique
bon bah le premier le plus ancien crâne
qu'on est le premier plus anciens restes
archéologiques on est homo sapiens en
afrique c'est le crâne de djebel i round
qui a trois cent mille ans et en afrique
du sud on a le crâne de floris bad que
vous voyez sur la droite ici qui à 260
milles ans donc ça c'est les premières
traces de l'homo sapiens sous sa forme
sous sa forme
anatomiquement archaïque et on a les
traces d'étude génétique on allait les
études génétiques des populations
humaines modernes
quand on y applique la loge moléculaire
et bien on trouve une origine d'homo
sapiens entre 120 mille et trois cent
mille ans là vous avez le l'étude la
plus récente qui placent clairement
l'origine d'homo sapiens plutôt autour
de 300 mille ans autour de 220 mille ans
donc ça c'est bon cdh qui sont
relativement débattue mais donc les
preuves génétiques plus les preuves
archéologiques montrent que homo sapiens
est présent en afrique depuis au moins
trois cent mille ans donc on s'attend à
trouver des gens qui étaient qu'ils
étaient capables de trouver des fossiles
à cette époque déjà depuis trois cents
mille ans était-il réellement capables
ces gens de trouver des fossiles
bah on ad on a quand même des traces que
ces gens étaient capables d'avoir une
pensée abstraite
même s'ils sont anatomiquement
archaïques comme vous pouvez le voir sur
le crâne de floris bad ici on est sur
une forme à anatomiquement archaïque
avec un visage très large mais très
large des bourrelets sus orbite est
encore bien prononcé un front
relativement fuyant mais néanmoins à
cent mille ans eh bien on trouve déjà
des preuves d'une certaine pensée
abstraite et d'une certaine pensée non
utilitaires voilà j'ai envie de dire
avec notamment cette trace doc ras lors
ces traces d'hommes qu'on n'en parlera
plus en détail dans l'évolution du
cerveau le cours sur l'évolution du
cerveau qui est à venir dans quelques
semaines mais en gros ici vous avez
cette trace d'autres et se boude ocre il
a des gravures et ses gravures
ce sont des gravures géométriques qui
n'ont aucun rôle utilitaire
donc ça c'est un signe interprété comme
un c'est interprété comme un signe de
pensée abstraite daté de 80 mille ans et
ici vous avez un collier les restes d'un
collier en fait en coquillages donc ces
coquilles ont été percés et on voit
qu'en fait que la corde qui passait à
travers ses co qui a poli l'ouverture
dans les coquillages donc on est sûr
qu'il y avait une corde qui passaient au
travers
donc ça c'était un petit collier et ce
collier il avait une fonction bas comme
un collier moderne esthétique donc donc
encore une fois une preuve d'une
modernité cognitive chez ses premiers
humains au moins date et jusqu'à il ya
au moins cent mille ans comme j'ai dit
on en reparlera plus en détail de tout
ça dans une prochaine dans une prochaine
vidéo mais pour l'instant l'idée c'est
que ces homo sapiens qui vivait à
l'époque qu'on appelle le paléolithique
moyen tout archaïque qu'il soit était
capable de réfléchir exactement comme on
le fait nous aujourd'hui et encore une
fois je le dis on en reparlera dans une
prochaine vidéo mais en tout cas ils
pensaient comme nous et puis à l'époque
et ben l'afrique du sud
il y avait déjà plein de fossile de dent
parce que c'était jamais qu'il y à trois
cent mille ans alors vous avez au niveau
de l'histoire fossiles de l'afrique vous
avez tous depuis
3 5 milliards d'années donc il ya trois
cent mille ans il y avait déjà des
fossiles de trois milliards d'années de
500 millions d'années de 250 millions
d'années enfin des fossiles qui datent
de d'aussi loin que la vie puisse
remonter des fossiles de thérapie site
vous aviez des fossiles de dinosaures
bref il y avait déjà des fossiles y a
trois cent mille ans et ces fossiles
étaient les mêmes que ceux d'aujourd'hui
parce que géologiquement 300 mille ans
c'est rien du tout ça équivaut presque à
aujourd'hui
donc là on suppose du moins que le les
fossiles étaient présents à peu près au
même endroit
ils sont et non pas bougé depuis trois
cents mille ans voilà donc ici vous avez
ce qu'on appelle la paléo senti victime
a donc là qui est une carte en fait qui
représente la richesse en fossiles plus
et rouge et plus et riche en fossiles et
vous pouvez voir qu'il ya un bon tiers
de l'afrique du sud qui est quand même
rouge écarlate
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya quand même un
gros gros gros paquet fossiles en
afrique du sud elle vous avez notamment
la région du caroux si vous avez vu le
cours sur le sur la bio stratigraphie du
carreau vous voyez ici la région du
caroux qui ressort rouge écarlate ici
cette région du carrousel une la des
hotspots fossilifère que le monde entier
envie à l'afrique du sud quoi et puis
évidemment vous avez d'autres endroits
qui sont très intéressants ici notamment
dans les montagnes du cap
vous avez lors de vie siens jusqu'au
dévonien là qui est très qui est très
fossilifère ici dans la région du cap
donc des fossiles en afrique du sud il y
en a toujours eu aussi loin qu'au mot
sapiens ait pu exister donc on finit
avec l'équation suivante une grande
richesse de fossiles qui existait déjà
qui préexistait à homo sapiens plus une
occupation humaine qui est aussi vieille
que l'humanité elle même
eh bien on a forcément donc est égal à
des découvertes de fossiles qui ont dû
prédaté l'invention même du mot
paléontologie et même l'arrivée des
colons des premiers colons même si la
première trace écrite de deux fossiles
découverts en afrique du sud et une
trace écrite
des colons il ya quand même il ya
forcément eu étant donné la longueur de
l'occupation humaine et la richesse en
fossiles du du coin il ya forcément eu
des découvertes très colonial qui ont
été faites avant maintenant la grande
question c'est où sont ses preuves ou
sont à atton conserver des traces parce
que c'est parce que il ya sept ya le
fait déjà que la culture était non
écrite la tradition était orale avant
l'arrivée des colons là la principale
façon dont ce dans la culture se
transmettait était à l'oral avant
l'arrivée des colons donc hâte ont
conservé des traces de deux sets de 7
paléontologie très colonial la question
n'est pas est ce que cette paléontologie
précoloniale existait elle a forcément à
exister statistiquement c'est impossible
qu'ils aient pas eu des humains qui ai
vu des fossiles avant maintenant la
question c'est à ton conserver une trace
existe-t-il des traces alors on sait que
avant la colonisation les populations
locales en afrique du sud et en afrique
en général étaient intéressés par la
géologie
il avait notamment y avait notamment
toute une industrie minière avant la
colonisation alors appeler ça une
industrie c'est pas au sens moderne
évidemment un
je parle d'industries comme on parle
d'industrie lithiques pour lâcher les
uns ou le mac d'aller où le banc n'ont
peut-être pas le magdalénien c'est pas
trop les industries lithiques mais bref
le voilà la lâche les halles les bifaces
et c'est une industrie l'éthique
donc il y avait une industrie de
l'industrie minière avant et on le sait
parce que bas il ya des endroits comme
greta zimbabwe mapangou est et puis
l'empiré du mali par exemple qui
produisait de l'or la principale source
d'or médiéval dans le bassin
méditerranéen
c'était le mali donc il y avait une
industrie de l'or avant même une
industrie minière
avant même la colonisation et l'empiré
du mali s'est construit sur cette cette
richesse en or l' empire médiévale du
mali s'est construit sur cette richesse
en or c'est même une des choses qui a
qui a accéléré la colonisation la
recherche des sources de cet or est donc
en afrique du sud on à maps ou google
qui a fourni ce magnifique petit
rhinocéros sculptée
en or et ça c'est ça ça prouve bien que
d'une il y avait une industrie minière
et que deux il y avait une métallurgie
ensuite il y a parmi les peuples
chasseurs cueilleurs et bien on a
retrouvé des traces de leur intérêt pour
des pour la géologie notamment un quartz
qui a été retrouvé le petit quartz que
vous voyez la gauche vous voyez qu'il
est taillé c'est un quartz taille et qui
a été placée délibérément dans l'orbité
d'un enfant avant qu'il est qu'il soit
enterré donc ça c'est pareil ses rituels
donc ça veut dire que ce quartz il avait
une fonction rituelle
on n'a pas vraiment idée de ce que
c'était mais il a été placé ici il a été
placé là délibérément il a été taillé
délibérément et placez-la délibérément
pour ça donc ça montre un intérêt aussi
pour cette ressource qu'est le quartz
des le middle stone age donc dès le
paléolithique moyen est en haut à droite
vous avez une fulgurante les fulgurantes
ce sont des ce sont des roches qui se
forme quand les clercs tap le sable et
les condamne donc les échos ihsane c'est
ce que nous on sait ce que nous en
france on appellerait les bushmen
mais en afrique du sud on les appelle
les condamne donc les bushmen appelle
ses fulgurantes des des pierres de
tonnerre donc ou des pierres des clercs
c'est exactement ce que ça veut dire
là c'est exactement ce que ça veut dire
ce qui veut dire que l'école san malgré
le fait qu'il n'avait pas établi de
science comme au sens occidental du
terme
l'écho et ça n'avait quand même
totalement conscience de l'origine avait
totalement conscience de l'origine de
ces pierres ils savaient ces ils savent
que ces pierres sont formés par les
éclairs qui tape dans le sable et ils
savent quand ils en trouvent une que
c'est un éclair qui a déjà frappé le
sable il ya très longtemps qui a formé
cette pierre et ça ça peut-être encore
une fois ça paraît être de la logique
élémentaire mais c'est pas si évident
que ça c'est pas si évident que ça ça
demande une projection dans le passé ça
demande une projection dans les
phénomènes de la nature sa demande d'une
compréhension des phénomènes de la
nature
et ça c'est le début de la science c'est
le début de la science
badir platon quand il disait mais c'est
ça en fait il faut se représenter c'est
que quand plate on dit ça on dit c'est
de la philosophie grecque mais alors
quand accueille samedi ça on dirait
c'est juste du bon sens voyez c'est ça
que j'appelle c'est ça qu'on appelle le
changer de perspective
voilà c'est que il ya des choses dont on
se dit bah oui c'est que du bon sens bah
oui mais quand platon a dit ça il ya
2000 ans on a dit c'est de la
philosophie grecque
alors quelle est la différence bat la
différence c'est qu'il n'a pas voilà la
différence c'est que pour nous la
philosophie grecque est essentiel parce
que c'est un événement fondateur de
notre culture occidentale alors qu'un co
et san qui trouve une fulgurante pour
nous c'est une anecdote
voilà et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
changer de perspective on ne réécrit pas
l'histoire mais on change juste la
perspective donc voilà tout ça ça nous
conduit à la question mais depuis quand
les humains sont-ils capables de trouver
des fossiles les êtres humains moderne
homo sapiens et depuis quand l'ont-il
faire en afrique du sud est où sont ses
preuves
donc quand est ce qu'il ya de marrant
c'est de comparer ça avec l'europe aussi
puisque en europe on a ce silex taillés
de 200 mille ans qui a été taillée par
un néandertal et qui a été taillée
exprès pour garder ce petit coquillage
là que vous voyez au milieu et ce petit
coquillage c'est pas un coquillage
moderne c'est un coquillage dans un
rognon de silex un coquillage fossilisé
du crétacé qui a 100 millions d'années
ce coquillage de vieux de cent millions
d'années dans le silex a été retrouvée
par néandertal néandertal qui a taillé
autour de ce coquillage pour le mettre
en valeur
ou du moins c'est l'hypothèse qu'on fait
même qu'ils arrêtent est taillé pour
être mises en valeur
alors il y en a qui font des adaptations
enfin des interprétations qui sont
purement fonctionnelle de ce coquillage
fin de ceux de ceux ci l'ex en disant
que bah oui ils ont taillé là où c'était
pas fragilisé par le coquillage web
enfin j'ai envie de dire qu'à ce niveau
là étant donné la quantité de silex
qu'on retrouve aussi bien en angleterre
qu'en france il aurait pu juste le
balancer leurs oignons de silex
je veux dire il n'y avait pas d'intérêt
à perdre du temps à tailler un rognon de
silex autour de quelque chose de ce
coquillage qui aurait été interprété
comme une fragilité à l'intérieur du
rognon de silex veut dire il ya
suffisamment de silex dans le monde pour
le
lancée le crétacé s'est littéralement
truffé de renault en silex pourquoi
avoir collecté celui là dans ce cas donc
la seule raison la seule réponse viable
à ça ça c'est le coquillage a été mis en
valeur par le taillage duby face au tour
de autour de ce coquillage et ça pareil
ça montre une certaine pensée abstraite
par néandertal donc maintenant la grande
question c'est chez homo sapiens en
afrique
qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà ça c'est la
preuve que néandertal le faisait
maintenant où sont les preuves que
sapiens le faisait depuis quand sapiens
l'at il fait donc ce que je vais vous
présenter à partir de maintenant c'est
la synthèse d'un article qu'on a écrit
avec des collègues notamment charles
celm des collections d'africains et
adrienne mayor qui avait écrit ses
livres le premier chasseur de fossiles
en europe et en amérique
donc c'est une synthèse de cet article 2
qui recense la littérature sur justement
les découverte géologique et
paléontologique pré coloniale en afrique
et ça et si vous êtes intéressés pour
pouvoir cet article pour lire cet
article vous n'avez qu'à me faire savoir
en commentaire alors je sais pas
peut-être que j'aurais oublié de mettre
un lien dans les commentaires
dans la description de la vidéo donc si
j'ai oublié de mettre un lien dans la
description de la vidéo
faites le moi savoir en commentaire et
je vous mettrais amiens donc on commence
par la plus vieille preuve de collecte
de fossiles en afrique et 7 plus vieille
preuve de collecte de fossiles en
afrique et bien c'est à petit c'est un
petit ortho sert donc les hôtes auxerre
ce sont des mollusques qui vivait au
paléozoïque essentiellement mais ils ont
survécu jusqu'au trille à ce don ce sont
des ce sont des longues coquille conique
fait de différentes chambres et il y
avait un mollusque à l'intérieur donc un
céphalopode qui ressemblait à une
pieuvre
enfin plutôt un hôte il d'ailleurs ils
sont plutôt c'est comme un hôte il en
fait mais déroulé un art au cern est
donc ce set au serbe qui datent du trias
a été retrouvée loin de l'endroit où
l'on trouve normalement des orteaux sert
fossiles dans un abri sous roche dans
une grotte et cette grotte
elle était occupée par homo sapiens
sous sa forme anatomiquement archaïque à
savoir le même homo sapiens qui a été
découvert à jebel lire houde donc ici le
manu port donc le manuport c'est quelque
chose qui a été manuellement transporté
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça un
manuport donc ce manuport de erfoud qui
est une qui est une grotte au maroc a
exactement le même âge que le crâne de
djebel est rude que vous voyez sur la
gauche de l'écran
donc c'est donc on suppose que c'est cet
homo sapiens archaïque qui a été
retrouvé non loin de dire ce sont deux
localités aux marocains à erfoud haywood
donc c'est ce sont ces deux ces deux
localités on pense que l'une a donné le
crâne l'autre a donné le manuport mais
le mal du port a lui-même été retrouvés
dans avec de l'industrie lithique qui
correspond à la même industries
lithiques que celle retrouvés à djebel
est rude
donc c'est pas quand même une grosse
hypothèse de dire que ces leçons les
homo sapiens archaïques les mêmes 4gb
les routes qui ont du moins la même
population évidemment pas exactement les
mêmes spécimens les mêmes individus mais
ce sont ces la même population on va
dire d'homo sapiens sous leurs formes
archaïques anatomiquement archaïque qui
ont transporté ces sortes auxerre jusque
là jusque dans la grotte
maintenant vous êtes vous avez
probablement remarqué la forme de cet
auxerre qui n'a rien à voir avec les
autos serre que vous pouvez voir sur la
gauche vous voyez ici ce sont des
orteaux sert marocains donc de la même
époque du trias donc vous voyez que
c'est vous voyez à quoi il ressemble en
général donc le bout ici que vous voyez
là c'est ce bout 6 et donc vous voyez
bien que ce sont des orteaux serre
puisque ils ont un siphon centrale
contrairement aux à mo'nique qui ont
ainsi fonds qui serait collé à la à
l'extérieur en fête de la coquille donc
il s'agit des mêmes types de fossiles
c'est juste que celui de erfoud
curieusement ressemble à un pénis mme et
donc il ya des hypothèses qui tourne
autour du fait que peut-être se magne
port der food aurait été transportée
justement parce qu'il ressemblait à un
pénis précisément pour servir dans un
genre de rituel de la fertilité ou
quelque chose comme ça
là on est sur le domaine de l'hypothèse
on essaie de comprendre pourquoi il a
été transporté mais on ne remet pas en
question le fait qu'il a été transporté
ça c'est certain qu'il ait à plusieurs
kilomètres de là des endroits où
normalement on est censé retrouver ce
genre de rto serbe la grotte ne se
trouve pas juste à côté des
affleurements aorte auxerre ou même à
l'intérieur des affleurements ortho sert
donc il ya eu transport définitivement
et dépôts en contexte archéologique la
grande question c'est le pourquoi
peut-être un rituel de la fertilité
peut-être une genre d'une simple
curiosité on ne saura pas mais en tout
cas quoi qu'il arrive ce manuport de
erfoud qui a trois cent mille ans qui a
à peu près 300 mille ans c'est la
premier fossile ayant été transportée
c'est la première trace qu'on a d'un
transport de fossiles par homo sapiens
voilà ça au moins on peut en être sûr
ensuite on continue on est alors à
partir de 300 mille ans on entre dans le
paléolithique moyen mais paléolithique
moyen au middle stone age
il yad'autres manu port qui ont été
rapportés à cette époque cette époque du
middle stone age et notamment en afrique
du sud où on a des trilobites beaucoup
de trilobites qui ont été transportés
ils sont pas tous très très bien dater
donc on sait qu'ils sont du
paléolithique moyen en général peut être
autour de 40 mille ans on n'est pas sûr
mais en tout cas ce qu'ont selon on est
certain c'est qu'encore une fois ils ont
été transportés et comme le manioc port
de erfoud ils ont été prélevés dans un
affleurement et transporté dans un abri
sous roche où ils ont été redéposé en
contexte archéologique
donc c'est trilobites là que vous voyez
il date du paléozoïque ils ont plusieurs
centaines de millions d'années
et pourtant ils ont été retrouvés dans
des couches qui elle date de seulement
quelques milliers d'années
donc ça ça montre bien qu'il y à eu
remaniement
ces fossiles et notamment remaniement
intentionnelle par un être humain qui a
prélevé ces fossiles d'un endroit les a
transportés pour une raison ou pour une
autre les a déposés dans un autre
endroit et vous avez notamment
alors ici vous avez un trilobites qui
n'est pas super jolie donc c'est un peu
difficile de comprendre ce qui a pu
intéresser les hommes préhistoriques
dans le transport de celui là par contre
vous avez celui ci celui de fly place et
celui de fly place lui il est enroulé il
très très très beau c'est un très très
beau trilobites et donc on n'a pas trop
de mal à comprendre ce qui a pu
interloqués les les hommes
préhistoriques qui vivait à l'époque en
afrique du sud
néanmois est ce que c'est et rituels
est-ce que c'est esthétique est ce que
c'était de la pure curiosité
est-ce que c'était pour jouer aux billes
pour servir de monnaie d échange
est-ce que c'était pour jeter sur les
gens qu'ils aiment pas on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas ça ce serait ce sera un
grand mensonge mais quoi qu'il arrive
encore une fois il s'agit des premiers
fossiles qui ont été trouvés et
transporté intentionnellement en afrique
du sud c'est la première preuve de
paléontologie sud africaine qu'on a donc
déjà possiblement aussi vieille que
quarante mille ans et est déjà
encore une fois je tiens à insister sur
le fait qu' on peut appeler ça les
premières preuves de paléontologie
ça veut déjà dire que ces roches ces
rochers que sont les fossiles parce que
les fossiles sait jamais que du caillou
ça veut déjà dire que ces roches avait
une importance particulière
les hommes qui vivaient au paléolithique
ont vu ces fossiles et ont reconnu en
eux quelque chose de différent de
suffisamment différent pour justifier
dans le cas de fly place quelque chose
de suffisamment différent pour les
transporter sur des centaines de
kilomètres
parce que fly place ça se trouve du côté
du cap le fossile lui même vient de la
région qui s'appelle le cdh aarberg donc
il ya des centaines de kilomètres entre
les deux donc dire que et ça se sait
transport de fossiles sur des longues
distances ça ne peut se justifier que
par un intérêt particulier pour ces
fossiles en question et cet intérêt
particulier bien c'est l'ancêtre de la
paléontologie
c'est ni plus ni moins que l'ancêtre de
la batterie paléontologie donc même si
on ne sait pas même si on est à peu près
sûr que c'était pas pour la science
qu'ils n'ont fait clairement il ya
quelque chose qui les a intéressés dans
ces fossiles ensuite on arrive en egypte
ancienne donc là on est on a fait un
saut dans le temps assez conséquent on
est maintenant à
il un peu plus de 1000 avant jésus
christ est ce que vous voyez là c'est un
fossile d'oursins et alors ce fossile
d'oursins il n'a pas été retrouvée
n'importe comment
il a été retrouvé dans un ancien temple
donc encore une fois en contexte
archéologique dans un ancien temple et
dans cette aide sur ce fossile dur ça
vous pouvez voir qu'il y adhérer
hiéroglyphes qui ont été gravés dessus
et c'est hiéroglyphes alors je ne suis
pas capable de lire le hiéroglyphe mais
ça représente le nom le nom de quelqu'un
peut être de la personne qui a trouvé le
fossile mais en tout cas c'est un nom
c'est un nom de peut-être d'un prêtre et
il a été déposée intentionnellement dans
un temple et c'est pas la seule c'est
pas le seul cas qu'on a de collecte de
fossiles qui ont été retrouvés dans des
temples et on avait notamment des
exemples de fossiles doursat qui ont non
seulement été retrouvés dans des temples
mais qui ont en plus été retrouvés parmi
d'autres coquillages qui eux n'étaient
pas des faux cils et là c'est très très
important ça c'est très c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'il est en
train de ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que ce sont des faux cils
d'oursins des oursins fossiles du
caillou et ses faux cils doursat ont été
déposés donc transporté
intentionnellement et déposer
intentionnellement avec d'autres
coquillages moderne non fossilisés et ça
ça veut dire que nos anciens égyptiens
ont reconnu dans cet ours 1-1 individus
d'une espèce biologique c'est
l'identification de l'origine biologique
des fossiles et encore une fois pour
vous ça veut peut-être encore une fois
pour vous trouver un oursin et dire bah
ouais c'est un oursin c'est comme un
oursin moderne mais en cailloux pour
vous c'est peut-être que du bon sens
mais encore une fois d'un point de vue
histoire des sciences
l'identification de l'origine biologique
des fossiles vous gueulez c'est léonard
de vinci
et alors là d'un seul coup ça devient du
génie voyez
voilà un égyptien fait ça il ya 3000 ans
tout le monde s'en fout c'est du bon
sens mais encore une fois on fait ça en
europe
en 1500 après jésus-christ et alors là
si c'est léonard de vinci qui l'a fait
ça devient du génie changement de
perspective
une fois de plus ce changement de
voyez vous quand on vous dit ça c'est ça
j ai le droit à tous les coups j ai le
droit mais à tous les coups à chaque
fois que je parle de ça on me dit bah
oui mais c'est normal c'est du bon sens
c'est du bon sens de dire bah ouais vous
avez un ours un fossile les oursins
fossiles surtout ces sources un fossile
qui datent de l'éocène vous avez un
ancien fossile de l'éocène ça ressemble
vachement aux oursins qu'on a
aujourd'hui évidemment que c'est
évidemment que c'est la même chose
évidemment que c'est d'origine
biologique donc les eaux les égyptiens
c'est pas des génies ils ont juste ont
juste fait une hypothèse raisonnable
quoi dit oui mais quand on vous quand
leonard de vinci dans les années 1500 il
vient vous dire que les fossiles sont
d'origine biologique d'un seul coup
c'est du génie je veux dire quand il dit
exactement la même chose deux mille ans
plus tard c'est du génie alors que les
égyptiens ça veut dire
enfin bon bref on va pas s'énerver mais
c'est juste le côté ou pourquoi c'est du
génie quand c'est léonard de vinci et
c'est juste du bon sens quand c'est les
anciens égyptiens
non c'est du génie c'est du génie ils
ont reconnu l'origine biologique des
fossiles il y a trois mille ans il y a
trois mille ans
c'est beau c'est beau ce qui est en
train de se produire je dirais c'est
déjà et encore une fois ça n'a pas été
fait dans un but scientifique ils les
ont déposés dans des temples donc ça a
été fait dans un but rituel et pourtant
même si ça n'a pas été fait dans un but
scientifique
ben ils ont quand même compris quelque
chose de scientifiquement valide
qu'aujourd'hui on interprète comme
scientifiquement valide c'est comme je
le dis c'est la naissance de la
paléontologie des petites briques de la
paléontologie qui s'empilent les unes
sur les autres
et puis en egypte on a aussi un autre un
autre cas qui est très très intéressant
en egypte antique encore une fois c'est
que dans un temple dédié à 7
on a retrouvé des fossiles des ossements
fossilisés essais et on en a retrouvé
trois tonnes 3 tonnes d'ossements
fossilisés tous soigneusement empaquetée
dans du l'un est dédié à cette enfin du
moins déposé dans un temple dans un
temple qui a été dédiée à cette et ça
c'est si je veux dire ça veut dire ça
veut dire que non seulement ils sont pas
tombé dessus par hasard sur les fossiles
parce qu'ils y sont retournés le dire
ils ont pas ramené trois tonnes de
fossiles comme ça d'un coup je veux dire
il avait un gisement
ils ont localisé ils l'ont exploité et
ils ont elles ont accumulé en masse dans
un donc c'est la première collection de
masse de fossiles et c'est la première
aussi utilisation religieuse avérée de
fossiles avec c'est avec ces dépôts dans
des temples de l'egypte de l'egypte
antique c'est la première utilisation
religieuses on verra qui en a eu
d'autres
et même en europe d'ailleurs des
utilisations religieuses nous en europe
on a une longue histoire
d'interprétation des fossiles comme
étant des géants bibliques notamment du
moins dans le bain même dans le bassin
méditerranéen en général dans le vin
dans le monde catholique
voilà dans le monde chrétien même on va
dire en général on a une longue histoire
de l'interprétation des fossiles comme
étant des restes de la bible voilà donc
c'est pas la première c'est pas la seule
utilisation religieuse mais en tout cas
c'est la première et en plus c'est la
première collection en masse de fossiles
ce qui indique donc le repérage d'un
gisement même si on n'a pas vraiment
retrouvé le gisement en question
aujourd'hui mais il ya eu les égyptiens
ont repéré un gisement et on exploiter
ce gisement
donc c'est la première exploitation d'un
gisement avérée on va dire c'est pas
juste des fossiles sur lesquels ils sont
tombés par hasard on fait un autre bond
immense dans le temps et là on arrive
aux maisons aux russes alors le mézo
russe que vous voyez ici à l'image sur
la gauche c'est le mésozoïque de paris
c'est celui qui se trouve au muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris
et se met aux oreilles c'est bien il a
une longue et triste histoire qui
commence en afrique du sud il y a
c'était à peu près dans les années 1800
même si on n'a pas de date exacte début
des années 1800 probablement 1820 donc
dans les années 1820 à peut-être une
personne d'origine gris quoi qui est une
population d'afrique du sud de qu'on
retrouve dans lequel enfin au bord du
kalahari à la limite entre le caroux et
le kalahari dans la dans la région de
kimberley aujourd'hui il ya kimberley
comme grands centres urbains de la
région donc une personne d'origine gris
quoi collecte ce fossile de mézos risque
qui est une plaque une plaque avec un
maison aux riches dessus et ça contre
empreinte collecte ce fossile et
l'utilisent comme comme couvercle
ornementale pour impôts enfin pour une
alors ils disent à un pote ça peut ça
peut dire peau ou casseroles et je suis
pas complètement sûrs d'eux cissokho
casseroles en l'occurrence qui veut le
dire en tout cas voilà il est utilisé
comme couvercle ornementé pour un
récipient et dont vous avez de deux
français qui sont qu'on appelle les
frères verrou alors je crois qu'à
l'époque ils étaient deux ils étaient
trois en fait il y avait trois frères
verrou en afrique du sud mais à l'époque
ils étaient déjà plus que deux donc vous
avez les frères verrou qui sont passés
par là alors les frères verrou ils sont
ils sont connus pour avoir pour avoir
fait pas mal de choses assez sale avec
les populations indigènes notamment
pillé des tombes et probablement volé le
fossile de mais autorise que vous voyez
là alors je n'ai pas il n'ya aucun
rapport écrit à ma connaissance disant
que les frères verreault ont volé le
fossile
c'est juste que commencer par ailleurs
ce qu'ils ont fait dans la région et
notamment pillé des tombes et volé et
volé des objets culturels par ci par là
ça on le sait par contre il est possible
que le tas il ya eu les oreilles ça
m'étonnerait ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
aient les mecs aient eu suffisamment peu
de scrupules pour piller des tombes aimé
qu'ils aient acheté le fossile quoi
c'est sale et c'est ça l'idée quoi
et puis surtout à l'époque pie ix et des
tombes et volé des trucks était normale
entre guillemets c'était c'était il n'y
avait pas vraiment il n'y avait pas
vraiment de scrupules autour de ce à
quoi bon bref la pole la polarité moral
autour de ce genre de comportement était
très clairement en faveur de ce genre de
comportement voilà c'est juste ça que je
veux dire donc c'était même pas
aujourd'hui évidemment le conte son
interprète cela comme du pillage
culturel mais à l'époque le pillage
culturel ça n'existait pas vraiment
c'était pas une notion qui existait
vraiment donc bref tout ça pour dire que
semer zozos russe a probablement été
volé à l'époque ce qui était l'un des
moindres truc que les frères verreault
ont fait les vainqueurs de toutes façons
comme j'ai dit alors oui ils ont pillé
des tombes et des tombes royales
il ya aussi ça qu'il faut dire c'est
aussi ça qu'il faut préciser c'est à
dire qu'il y avait un roi qui avait été
enterré un roi gris quoi qu'ils avaient
été enterrés ils sont allés piller la
tombe du roi gris quoi qui venait d'être
enterré voilà donc il faut faut quand
même faut quand même avoir assez peu de
scrupules
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je dis que
bon si ça n'aura pas déranger d'aller
piquer le cadavre du roi d'aller piquer
des vases à droite et à gauche je pense
pas que ça les aurait dérangé de piquer
le mézo russe bref
donc c'est une histoire longue et triste
et surtout le problème de cette histoire
longue et triste c'est que l'on ne sait
pas qui est cette personne
la personne d'origine gris quoi qui a
trouvé mais aux russes la personne qui
est responsable de la vraie découverte
on n'a pas son nom on a juste le nom des
frères verrou qui sont ceux qui ont
collecté le fossile voilà et on a le nom
de paul gervais qui est la personne qui
a décrit le fossile bien des années plus
tard je romps presque vingt trente ans
plus tard peut-être même 50 ans plus
tard je sais plus mais bref choix qui a
été décrit dans les années 1800 donc
avec quarante cinquante ans plus tard
1828 maintenant 1860 pardon il a été
décrit dans les années 1860 quelque
chose donc
ouais 40 50 ans plus tard quoi donc bref
tout ça pour dire que mes aux eaux
russes après la description de paul
gervais une fois que le fossile a
atterri à paris et bien semer aux orris
il va s'avérer être la des fossiles les
plus importants au monde
pas aussi importants certes que
l'australopithèque de tangue mais là des
fossiles les plus importants au monde
pour l'établissement de la théorie de la
dérive des continents mais aux orris
fait partie de ces fossiles qu'on
retrouve sur deux continents différents
et qui montre que donc ces deux
continents étaient reliés les uns aux
autres mais aux eaux russes est un
organisme qui vivaient dans de l'eau
dans l'eau d'une mer intérieure
c'est pas ça fait pas partie de ces
organismes qui aurait pu faire des
grandes traversées voit les deux des
grandes traversées maritimes
donc c'est pour ça que c'est un argument
intéressant les eaux russes puis après
il a été supplémenté par des listes
roseaux russe dès le saut de teris ce
que vous voyez là et plein d'autres
fossiles qu'on a retrouvé sur différents
continents et qui ont donc fini par
montrer qu'en fait ces continents
étaient connectés les uns aux autres
donc c'est un fossile qui s'est avéré
par la suite extrêmement important pour
l'établissement de la théorie de la
dérive des continents et on ne saura
jamais qui a découvert ce fossile
extrêmement important et ça c'est quand
même assez triste voilà et pour ce que
ça nous concerne nous eh bien on va
surtout marqué que c'est la première
découverte d'un fossile du caron et oui
les fossiles du caroux aussi abondant
soit il la première trace de découverte
d'un de ces fossiles du caroux la
première trace avérée de la découverte
d'un de ces fossiles du caroux elle ne
date que de 1800 aider et ça c'est ça
c'est enfin quand vous savez l'abondance
des fossiles dans le karoo on se rend
compte à quel point c'est probablement
complètement faux
vient il ya tellement de fossiles dans
le karoo tellement d'ossements qui
traînent partout et tout ça tellement de
liste rose aux russes et de dictons que
c'est impossible que les bushmen n'en
est pas collectés c'est impossible et
pourtant la seule
la première preuve qu'on a c'est ce mais
autorise seulement dans les années 1800
donc c'est vous dire c'est vous dire la
quantité d'informations qu'on manque
dans cette dans cette recherche en fait
de quels étaient les premiers les
premiers chercheurs les premiers
paléontologues sud-afrique quoi ces
sachants la quantité de faux cils qui a
et sachant l'occupation humaine on
devrait avoir des fossiles du quart aux
plus anciens que ça alors il ya une
autre occurrence qui est intéressante et
qui est à peu près aussi vieille un poil
plus jeunes et qui compte aussi comme du
caroux même si c'est pas le l'assemblage
du beaufort mais l'assemblage du storm
burg
enfin le groupe c'est pas le groupe du
bo former le groupe du sternenberg mais
ça compte quand même comme du caroux et
c'est le cas de la moc alikane donc la
grotte de mots cali au lesotho qui est
un cas qui date peut-être de la fin des
années 1800 ou du début des années 1900
donc là vous avez une image de la grotte
de mots cali qui est en fait une plutôt
un genre d'abris sous roche donc vous
avez des personnes ici qui vous donne un
peu l'échelle de la taille de cet
assemblage sur cette paroisse que vous
voyez cet abri sous roche
il y à des peintures et ici ce que vous
voyez là c'est là cette grotte
elle met enfin cet abri sous roche se
trouve lui-même dans la formation
clarins formation clarensky est connu
pour ses dinosaures et notamment entre
autres des empreintes de dinosaures on
trouve des empreintes de dinosaures dans
la formation clarins on en trouve dans
la formation elliott qui se trouve
généralement juste en dessous et on en
trouve dans la formation moleté nos qui
est encore une fois en dessous de la
formation elliott et comme on est au
lait aux autos en fait les pentes sont
raides
c'est la montagne le lesotho c'est le
drakensberg la montagne du dragon et on
se draguent engberg ce drakensberg tout
fait qu'il ya des dimanches relief en
fait là bas et du coup les pentes sont
plutôt raide donc généralement vous avez
rarement la formation clarins exposé
toute seule en fait vous avez toujours
l'assemblage moleté nos elliott clara
exposés tous ensemble au même endroit
quoi donc on a beaucoup d'empreintes de
pas et je sais où je veux en venir c'est
qu'on a des empreintes de pas dans les
trois formations et les trois formations
sont généralement toutes les trois
exposés en même temps dans les mêmes
vallée quoi dans les mêmes gorge
donc on a généralement beaucoup
d'empreintes de pas et donc voici un
exemple à droite très criants
d'empreintes de pas de dinosaures du
lesotho qui date généralement soit de la
fin du trias soit du début du jurassique
puisque la formation clarins et du
jurassique mais la formation elliott est
à moitié du trias est à moitié du
jurassique et donc dans la grotte de
moka liés on trouve ces peintures
rupestres enfin cette peinture rupestre
ici et là vous pouvez voir la forme à
trois feuilles qui est très typique
enfin trilobé on va dire plutôt par
trois feuilles mais trilobé qui est très
typique des empreintes de pas de
dinosaures et donc il a été proposé que
éventuellement 7
cette peinture soit la peinture faite
par des bushmen déco ihsane d'empreintes
de pas qui ont été découverte non loin
de là donc on a plain d'empreintes de
pas autour de la grotte de mots cali et
ça c'est intéressant parce que ben on a
le même phénomène qui a eu lieu à
plusieurs endroits dans le monde
à plusieurs endroits dans le monde
vous avez les des empreintes de pas de
dinosaures comme par exemple ici en
arizona un grand staircase au national
monument de escalante est donc là vous
avez aussi pareil cette peinture
rupestre trilobé qui correspond aux
empreintes de pas de dinosaures qui ont
été retrouvés non loin de là de cette
grotte donc c'est pareil là on a aussi
en amérique du nord une co occurrence
des empreintes de dinosaures et des
peintures rupestres
et des peintures rupestres en forme
d'empreintes de dinosaures et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que à chaque fois
elles sont peintes avec la pointe vers
le bas alors que nous on a l'habitude
généralement de dessiner des empreintes
de dinosaures avec la pointe enfin les
doigts pointant vers le haut c'est comme
un mot cali kave un mot cali kave vous
avez les empreintes qui sont peintes
avec les doigts pointant vers le bas
donc ça c'est un phénomène plutôt
intéressant je reviendrai sur scène
après je vais d'abord parlé de ça et
alors est ce qui est encore plus
intéressant à moka l'icade c'est que ces
empreintes de pas de dinosaures peintes
au mur était autrefois accompagné
d'autres d'autres peintures qui se sont
effacées avec le temps depuis ce que
vous voyez là c'est une photo récente la
photo ici c'est une photo récente mais
quand on regarde la publication
originale qui décrivait ses empreintes
faite par paul et lamberger un
missionnaire français en au lesotho
et bien cette description des delà des
empreintes
enfin des des peintures d'empreintes de
moka lichens elles sont accompagnées de
trois figures de trois figures et ces
trois figures ressemble énormément à des
autruches et du coup on en vient à se
demander mais est-ce que les bushmen qui
sont quand même deux fameux pisteurs
est-ce que les bushmen n'aurait pas déjà
compris que les empreintes de dinosaures
sont en fait des empreintes qui ont été
faits par de grands organismes
ressemblant à des oiseaux des organismes
très très gros ressemblant à des oiseaux
un très très gros parce que les
empreintes de dinosaures sont
généralement assez grande
même si toutes les empreintes du lesotho
ne sont pas gigantesques non plus mais
je veux dire on a des yeux bron tess qui
sont quand même assez gros sur les autos
mais bref il est ce qu'il n'avait pas
déjà compris que ses empreintes à trois
doigts donc très semblables à des
empreintes d'oiseaux coureurs modernes
n'ont pas été faites par justement de
des organismes ressemblant à des oiseaux
par le passé et est ce que ces peintures
ici que vous voyez là qui ressemble à
des autruches ne serait pas la première
tentative de reconstitution d'un
organisme et un qu'on appelle un dino
du coup là est ce que ce ne serait pas
l'une des premières tentatives de
reconstitution d'un dinosaure fait en
afrique par des bushmen ça c'est assez
tentant comme interprétation et ça
devient encore plus intéressant quand on
compare maintenant on reconstitution qui
était fait des dinosaures à peu près à
la même époque mais par les
scientifiques et notamment sur ricciardo
owen toi aussi tu as fait ta tintin
quand je les dis à vous toi aussi tu y
as pensé et un temps bref seul ricciardo
wayne donc qui dans les années
enfin des années 1800 même milieu des
années 1800 1842 il me semble invente le
terme dinosaures et tantes les premières
reconstitution de dinosaures dont vous
avez notamment celle de crystal palace
et puis vous avez ce dessin là que vous
voyez donc systématiquement ricciardo
wayne reconstruit les dinosaures comme
étant des reptiles qui ont les pattes
droite sous le corps mais par contre
qu'ils ne sont pas bipèdes ces
dinosaures sont quadrupède et ils ont la
queue qui traînent au sol la raison pour
laquelle il en arrive à cette conclusion
là bas c'est que il se base sur les
reptiles moderne et notamment les
crocodiles pour faire ces
reconstitutions et qu' il n'a que
quelques zoo à se mettre sous la dent il
n'a pas beaucoup à l'époque on ne
connaît pas beaucoup de dinosaures on
connaît que mégalo zaurus on doit
connaître iguanodon et puis on doit
connaître il y en a un autre c il a et
aux aurait peut-être je crois enfin bref
à l'époque on connaît pas grand chose
niveau dinosaures ou du moins on connaît
d'autres dinosaures mais on attend on
s'est pas encore rendu compte que
c'étaient des dinosaures donc ricciardo
wayne il a jamais que iguanodon et
mégalo zaurus à se mettre sous la dent
et c'est très très peu de fossiles
c'est très très peu d'ossements donc il
fait ce qu'il peut et à l'époque et bien
ils pensent que les dinosaures ressemble
à ça c'est à dire des crocodiles avec
les jambes droites sous le corps comme
des mammifères mais voyez avec avec cet
air extrêmement épais pato et 7 que qui
traînent au sol qu'on va retrouver
traînant au sol jusque dans les années
1990 1
toutes les reconstitutions de dinosaures
quelle qu'elle soit jusque dans les
années 90 et la popularisation de
nouveaux styles de dinosaures grâce à
jurassic park notamment cessé de ce
n'est qu'à ce moment là que les
dinosaures vont commencer à
systématiquement être représentée avec
la cure en l'air est plus là que
traînant au sol alors maintenant
comparons justement les les dinosaures
de moka l'icade les dinosaures de
ricciardo wayne donc à peu près
contemporains les uns des autres même si
comme je le dis on n'a pas vraiment de
date solide pour moque alikane mais on
pense qu'ils ont été fait à peu près la
même époque et les dinosaures tels qu'on
pense qu'il peut être enfin du moins
mégalo zaurus puisque là on part du
principe que ce sont des théropodes des
empreintes de dinosaures théropodes
assez grosse empreinte tridactyles donc
voilà un dinosaure théropode telle que
représentée par les bushmen un dinosaure
théropode telle que représentée par
richard de wayne est un dinosaure
théropode mégalo zaurus telle console
représente aujourd'hui est donc là le
jeu que j'aime bien faire avec les
étudiants celle à laquelle des deux
laquelle des deux représentations
anciennes est la plus fidèle à la
représentation moderne et là évidemment
c'est unanimement c'est la
représentation des corps sandé des
bushmen qu'ils l'emportent pour
plusieurs raisons donc déjà la posture
bipèdes 1 et la deuxièmement la queue
qui ne traînent pas au sol et alors
cette posture et la différence justement
elle est fondamentale et elle se trouve
en fait dans le fait que la
reconstitution qui a été fait par les
bushmen est basé sur des empreintes de
pas alors que la reconstitution qui est
fait par wayne et les reconstitutions
qui en général vont être faites par les
palais on trouve pas des paléontologues
durant le xxème siècle vont généralement
se baser sur des squelettes et non pas
sur les empreintes les empreintes vont
être pendant assez longtemps considérés
comme des
comme death ou fossile quoi comme des
trucs comme des anecdotes voilà
l'iconologie va vraiment prendre son
essor
c'est un fan technologie n'est pas
spécialement une science très récente
mais pendant très longtemps ça va être
plutôt être pris comme des faux cils
dessous zone quoi donc selick nologie va
pas être considérer très sérieusement
avant un bon moment dans la science
occidentale
par contre les bushmen e l'ichn au logis
ils connaissent bien ce sont
d'excellents pisteurs donc pour eux les
empreintes c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel
et c'est ainsi que du coup bas en
regardant les empreintes de dinosaures
qui lit aau lesotho et bien ils ont pu
constater que d'une part elle avait
trois doigts comme celles d'oiseau
moderne
donc d'où la silhouette générale
d'oiseaux qu'il n'y avait pas
d'empreintes de mains dont d'où la
posture bipèdes doux même l'absence
totale de mende ailleurs et ils ont
remarqué aussi qu'il n'y avait pas de
trace de queue entre les deux entre les
deux empreintes à chaque fois entre les
deux entre la jambe de gauche et la
jambe droite ils ont remarqué qu'il n'y
avait pas de trace de queue et d'où la
queue courte de ces de ces dinosaures de
ces dinosaures tels qu'ils les ont
imaginés et si ricciardone avait regardé
les empreintes de pas et bien il aurait
pu constater ça ils auraient pu
constater qu'il n'y avait pas de trace
de queue qui traînait au sol
contrairement à ce que les crocodiles
par exemple le laissent derrière eux et
ils auraient pu constater qu'il n'y
avait pas de trace de main non plus donc
ça ça nous conduit à penser que ces
peintures de moka l'icade ce sont les
premières reconstitution précise du mois
anatomiquement précise anatomiquement
juste de dinosaures au monde et ça c'est
pas rien c'est pas rien alors évidemment
sa part du principe que ces figurines
peintes à côté de la possible peinture
d'empreintes de pas représente bel et
bien des dinosaures mais quand même là
on a on a un assemblage de preuve qui
donne à penser que certainement les
bushmen s'était rendu compte qu'il y
avait des empreintes de pas que ses
empreintes de pas ressembler étrangement
à celles d'oiseau moderne et du coup sûr
les
ça leur a permis de reconstruire les
dinosaures tels qu'ils sont réellement
c'est à dire des animaux très
ressemblant à des oiseaux du moins les
dinosaures théropodes évidemment pas les
sauropodes
mais il ya pas d'empreintes de
sauropodes il n'y a pas de belles
empreintes de sauropodes en afrique du
sud dans le sud de l'afrique même de
manière générale donc donc ces
dinosaures théropodes et là où je
trouvais ça intéressant je vais revenir
la voilà là où c'est intéressant c'est
que c'est pas tellement une opposition
il faut pas tellement voir ça comme une
opposition entre entre la science
occidentale et la science sud-africaine
enfin science e précoloniale sud
africaine avec des guillemets mais il
faut vraiment voir ça comme une
opposition entre eux une science basée
sur les squelettes est une science basée
sur les technologies en fait le par
exemple lave à gauche vous avez un
déguisement de domme et me d'un
aborigène d'australie et il y avait des
empreintes de dinosaures qui était
interprétée comme appartenant à celle de
l'homme et me l'homme et me étant un
individu mythique ce qui montre du coup
qu'ils avaient compris que ses
empreintes de pas n'était pas récente
aussi puisqu'elle avait été faite par un
individu mythologiques
voilà donc l'homme et meuf et il avait
du coup compris aussi la nature à vienne
de ses empreintes du moins la relation
qu'il y avait avec les la branche la
plus proche des oiseaux parmi les
dinosaures et d'un autre côté vous avez
en amérique
donc là on est dans le monde anglo saxon
on a des empreintes de dinosaures dans
le connecticut qui sont représentés ici
alors qu'ils sont pas qu'ils sont pas
représentés thierry tridactyles mais qui
sont techniquement tridactyles mais là
c'est juste une précision de la gravure
elle-même ses empreintes du connecticut
donc encore une fois tridactyles était
interprétée comme appartenant aux
corbeaux queneau et à relâcher pour
savoir si le déluge était finie donc
encore une fois compréhension de la
nature à vienne des dinosaures à travers
les empreintes à travers les empreintes
que les dinosaures ont laissé donc c'est
vraiment les empreintes de pas en fait
ceux ci la science
assia sa naissance la science
paléontologique c'était plus rapidement
penché vers les empreintes et moins vite
penché vers les squelettes en fait la
nature à vienne des dinosaures auraient
été comprise quasiment instantanément
en fait on aurait pas eu ce long débat
sur pendant des années sur fin ça aurait
semblé une évidence en fait ça on
appelle ça une hypothèse nul en lui une
hypothèse de base
parce qu'évidemment français est nul ça
veut pas dire la même chose qu'eux en
anglais mais on appelle ça une hypothèse
de base en fait l'hypothèse de base ça
aurait été que les dinosaures sont plus
proches des oiseaux or en occident
historiquement ce qui s'est passé c'est
que les dinosaures ont été très
rapidement considéré comme des reptiles
comme des gros reptiles et du coup on a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à les
extirper de leur condition reptilienne
en tout cas jusqu'à la dinosaur
renaissance des années 70 donc ça vous
donne en fait c'est là où je disais
changer de perspective ça vous donne ce
côté
ce changement de perspective vous donne
aussi l'accès à une réalité alternative
j'ai envie de dire où le haut ricciardo
wen au lieu de regarder les ossements
auraient regardé les auraient regardé
les empreintes en gros et se et aurait
commencé à interpréter les dinosaures
comme des oiseaux et non pas comme des
reptiles et voilà vous pouvez vous
imaginer ce que serait la science ce que
serait la paléontologie aujourd'hui si
la paléontologie des dinosaures avaient
commencé comme ça en fait c'est
fascinant moi je trouve ça facile
bref et maintenant donc maintenant qu'on
a bien établi que les êtres humains
collecte des fossiles depuis toujours ma
la grande question depuis que l'homme
est homme comme disent les comme disent
les lycéens dans leur vie dans leur dans
leur dit certes de philo voilà depuis
que l'homme est homme ils collectent des
fossiles donc maintenant qu'on a bien
établi ça on peut se demander
du coup pourquoi que collecter des
fossiles si c'est pas pour la science
pas vrai parce qu'aujourd'hui la
collection des fossiles essentiellement
pour la science à moins que vous soyez
collectionneurs mais même si vous êtes
collectionneur vous avez quand même
conscience de l'intérêt scientifique des
fossiles vous ne collecter pas les
fossiles uniquement parce que parce
qu'ils sont jolis voulait collecter
aussi parce que vous avez conscience qu
ils ce sont des choses anciennes est
donc précieuse ce qui les rend précieuse
donc il ya toujours une idée de science
derrière voilà
et puis vous allez toujours essayé de
les dater vous avez toujours essayé de
les identifier selon les canons de la
science et vous avez toujours essayé de
les dater selon les canons de la science
donc mais on peut se demander du coup
mais si on n'a pas tous background
scientifique
à quoi bon collecter des fossiles
pourquoi les gens auraient collecté des
fossiles par le passé bon alors il ya
plusieurs catégories donc en tout cas
qu'on a listé dans notre article la
première catégorie c'est par accident
on n'est pas forcément on n'a pas
forcément conscience qu'on est en train
de collecter des fossiles quand on
collecte des fossiles c'est notamment le
cas dans les pyramides d'attendre les
pyramides d'égypte ce sont des immenses
collection de fossiles et ses faux cils
ce sont essentiellement des nullités
il ya aussi des fragments de coquillages
dedans mais ce sont essentiellement des
nues milite c'est à dire des
foraminifères est donc passé il s'agit
de fossiles qui ont été collectés par
les égyptiens pour construire les
pyramides mais il n'avait pas vraiment
conscience que c'était des faux cils du
mois on n'a pas vraiment de on n'a pas
vraiment de d'idées sur est-ce qu'ils
avaient vraiment conscience qu'il
s'agissait d'organismes marins anciens
on a hérodote qui est en fin du mois la
légende raconte que hérodote est le
premier à avoir fait l'hypothèse qu'il
s'agissait de lentilles mais bon bref
je sais même pas si c'est vrai en fait
faudrait que je vérifie
mais en tout cas voilà et puis vous avez
donc ce ce crâne de cétacés ça c'est un
exemple moderne donc le crâne de cétacés
qui a été retrouvé lui aussi en egypte
dans des carrières de calcaire ou le
calcaire est utilisé pour faire des
dalles et donc vous avez ce crâne de
cétacés qui a été coupée en tranches par
là par la disqueuse la ville se sont
rendus compte un peu trop tard qu'il y
avait un crâne de cétacés à l'intérieur
donc c'est le crâne d'un proto cette
idée qui a pu être étudiés quand même en
scannant justement en passant au scanner
saidal
donc voyez que c'est pas on peut
collecter des fossiles par accidents ça
arrive ça arrive même plus souvent qu'on
ne l'imaginé bien souvent les fossiles
ne sont même pas identifié en tant que
possible on a d'autres exemples ailleurs
en afrique notamment en tanzanie où vous
avez cette mosquée la grande la grande
mosquée de kilwa qui est fait en corail
vous voyez un détail d'un des melons de
corail qui a été utilisé pour construire
la mosquée donc là c'est pareil c'est
pas forcément dit qu'il ya une valeur
symbolique quelconque à ça c'est
peut-être juste qu'il leur fallait de la
pierre et que la pierre du coin c'est
duke oreilles voilà c'est du corail
fossilisés donc après peut-être que
effectivement il ya une valeur
symbolique qu'ils étaient au courant que
ce corail était fossilisés et
représentant représentait donc des
éléments vivants anciens mais bon ça on
le saura pas il ya l'utilisation
médicale des fossiles deuxième grande
catégorie l'utilisation médicinales
évidemment on ne peut pas ne pas citer
la chine la chine et co2 dragons qui
sont tous des fossiles de vertébrés et
qui sont toujours utilisés aujourd'hui
là vous avez par exemple
à gauche l'image d'un flacon que j'ai
enfin j'ai cherché sur ebay un dragon
balls sur e-bay appui ben vous vend des
dragonballs
sur ebay qui sont ni plus ni moins que
des fossiles réduit en poudre que vous
allez mettre dans votre thé et qui ont
des vertus médicinales
selon la tradition évidemment ces vertus
médicinales sont absolument inexistante
du mois pas au delà du placebo donc
n'achetez pas de fossiles pour vous en
faire du thé s'il vous plaît mais on va
pas se fout
trop de la tronche des chinois parce
qu'en france on a un truc qui s'appelle
la lithothérapie vous voyez ici par
exemple une page d'un livre de
lithothérapie que j'ai scanné et en haut
à gauche vous voyez du bois fossile donc
le bois fossile donc du bois pétrifié en
l'occurrence dubois silicifiées qui est
utilisé pour combattre la distraction et
la perte de mémoire donc voila vous
porter ça en pendentif et apparemment ça
combat la procrastination
alors je sais pas si vous avez du bois
fossile en pendentif
mais là depuis une heure et demie que
vous m'écoutez vous êtes bien en train
de procrastiner l'a peut-être que vous
en auriez besoin voilà
et alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est
qu'en afrique pendant ce temps là qu'est
ce qui se passe bien bah rien rien
contrairement à l'exemple précédent où
on peut connecter du des fossiles par
accident ou je vous ai montré des
exemples quasiment uniquement africain
bah là même uniquement africain ben là
pour le coup le l'utilisation
médicinales des fossiles en afrique on
en a aucune trace
modern war quéau logique et ça ça c'est
un truc que je ne m'explique pas toutes
les cultures du monde
on utilise une honte une utilisation
médicinale des fossiles où on tue une
utilisation médicinale des fossiles on a
les indiens d'amérique par exemple qui
utilisaient les os fossilisés comme des
éponges et les appliquer sur les plaies
et du coup la bleue love loss spongieux
pomper le sang et le pus de la plaie
donc ça c'est une utilisation médicinale
des fossiles et qui plus est qui et qui
a un effet au delà du placebo pour le
coup vous avez évidemment l'asie où il
ya des atouts léger dit toutes les
cultures dans tous les continents ont
des exemples d'utilisations médicinales
des fossiles voilà mais pas l'afrique
voilà c'est juste là où je veux en venir
et ça c'est quand même c'est quand même
louche c'est bizarre mais non c'est pas
toutes les civilisations non plus qu'ils
ont des utilisations médicinales des
fossiles mais c'est clair que là pour le
coup sachant que c'est très répandu
ailleurs c'est bizarre d'avoir et
sachant la diversité des cultures en
afrique
c'est bizarre de n'avoir
aucun exemple d'utilisation médicinales
des fossiles même pas en egypte antique
le dire pourtant on a plein d'exemples
de collecte de fossiles comme je voulais
dire en egypte antique mais on n'a pas
d'exemple d'utilisation ouvertement
médicinales quoi ensuite on abat
l'utilisation purement esthétiques comme
on en a parlé déjà avec juste voilà une
utilisation qui est bien c'est joli un
fossile c'est joli et voilà donc on a eu
l'exemple d'une maison rue salle qui a
servi de de couvercle pour un pur impôts
ou une casserole et puis bah si vous
gueulez ça si vous gueulez ça ou que
vous cherchez sur ebay bas sur ebay
voilà j'ai trouvé magnifique un
magnifique une magnifique cocotte minute
tout en calcaire tout en calcaire à du
maroc de l'ordovicien du maroc avec vous
le voyez à l'intérieur des des hameaux
noïd ça doit être une
ça doit probablement être une gogniat
tite du coup sévère de lucien du
dévonien je sais plus on va me dire là
les gens qui parce que moi je
m'intéresse pas ces fossiles du maroc
parce que c'est du pillage
donc les gens qui sont adeptes de la
recherche de fossiles du maroc vous
allez me dire de quelle de quel âge quel
âge ça ces trucs là je sais qu'on y
trouve il me semble que ça a le même âge
que les que les orthos r2 erfoud que
leur taux sert de erfoud et me semble
que c'est du trias bref vous le dirai
quel âge ils ont ces fossiles là parce
que personnellement je suis pas trop au
courant parce que à chaque fois qu'on
voit ces fossiles du maroc passé par là
bas c'est du pur pillage s'est revendu
comme ils en font même des chiottes le
dire ils font même des chiottes en
marbre fossilifère du maroc je trouve ça
aberrant
je trouve ça horrible mans aberrant donc
et le pire c'est qu'on en a tous un des
fossiles comme ça du maroc ça circule
tellement qu'on finit toujours par en
avoir
d'une manière ou d'une autre bref
toujours dans l'usagé esthétique on a
évidemment les bijoux donc les bijoux
comme lambres par exemple que vous
pouvez y à lambres de madagascar qui est
souvent due qu'aux pâle ou du faux des
fois c'est du faux donc septembre il est
il contient assez du fossile lui même
puisque c'est de ces deux là s'aiment
fossilisés et des fois il contient même
des insectes donc des fossiles à
l'intérieur du fossile donc ça et ça
vous pouvez le porter en pendentif
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont des des
bijoux qui contiennent de lambres et
dans le passé qu'est ce qu'on a on à
néandertal qui faisait des colliers avec
des fossiles
voilà donc ici vous avez un assemblage
de deux cement est dedans qui ont été
utilisés pour faire un collier vous
voyez ici la corde qui passait là la
petite annotation qui servait à faire
passer la corde ou le trou est ici va
vous avez un brachiopodes fossiles et ce
brachiopodes fossiles vous voyez qu'il
faisait partie du pendentif
voilà on peut faire des bijoux et ça
fait très très très longtemps qu'on fait
des bijoux même néandertal s'en faisait
des bijoux ensuite vous avez à
l'utilisation religieuse des fossiles ou
du moins une interprétation religieuse
des fossiles avec le fameux mythe des
dragons on a fait tout une vidéo sur le
lien entre fossiles et dragons il n'y a
pas vraiment de enfin on a fait le lien
entre dinosaures on a fait une vidéo qui
discutent du lien entre dinosaures et
dragon pour conclure qu'il n'ya pas de
lien
justement entre dinosaures et dragons
donc je vous invite à aller la voir mais
il ya quand même des liens entre
fossiles et dragons mais c'est pas des
fossiles de dinosaures donc par exemple
le dragon de klagenfurt dont le design
de cette fontaine a été directement
inspirée d'un crâne de rhinocéros makran
de rhinocéros fossiles un rhinocéros
laineux et en afrique du sud ou du moins
dans le sud de l'afrique
on a le mythe du columbo l'houmeau qui
est un
un genre de monstre reptilien ich voilà
aux allures reptilienne qui qui est
souvent associé aux empreintes de pas de
dinosaures qu'on trouve en abondance
justement dans le lesotho et dans la
région d'afrique du sud qu'on appelle le
30 sky
il y a le hamac en croco donc à mein
kampf poupaud arrivée elle prononcée
parce que c'est déclic c'est pas évident
qui est un qui est aussi un genre de
monstre reptiles you more voilà qui est
associé aux ossements et aux empreintes
qu'on retrouve en abondance dans cette
région et qui datent aussi de du début
du trias qui datent du trias et du début
du jurassic park donc on a des mythes
qui sont associées aux fossiles ça veut
pas dire que c'est les fossiles qui ont
inspiré les mythes ça veut dire qu'on
avait certainement un mythe d'un côté
les fossiles de l'autre et les deux qui
se sont retrouvés associés
ça veut pas forcément dire que là est à
l'origine de l'autre et puis évidemment
comme je voulais d'y aller mais le mythe
des géants en europe c'est les fossiles
ont été traditionnellement quasiment
systématiquement à attribuer à des
géants biblique le plus connu étant
goliath évidemment mais on a aussi t'es
où théo baucus alors les géants
bibliques ou mythologiques la mythologie
et en étant tenu enfin les mythologie
gréco-romaine étant tenu en très haute
estime par les populations médiéval et
de la renaissance
surtout de la renaissance d'ailleurs
donc bref généralement les fossiles en
europe ils étaient interprétées comme
des géants bibliques ou mythologiques et
on a quand même quelques exemples en
afrique comme par exemple cette dent
dans qui appartient à un éléphant on va
dire les mêmes d'ailleurs un éléphant
plutôt d'afrique en tout cas sur la
branche africaine de l'évolution des
éléphants moderne et cette dent est bien
là et est interprétée par saint-augustin
au 4e siècle comme appartenant à un
géant en saint-augustin c'est un saint
qui vivait en afrique du nord donc sept
dents elles provenaient de tunisie voilà
donc on a aussi le mythe des géants qui
a fait son incursion avec la chrétienté
quand la chrétienté étaient installés en
afrique du nord au quatrième siècle
à l'époque de l'empiré romain et puis
évidemment on a des utilisations dans
des tombes et dans des temples ou là le
l'interprétation religieuse ne fait
quasiment aucun doute donc en europe
on a par exemple cette tombe à gauche
c'est en angleterre je crois où on a des
oursins fossiles qui ont été disposés en
cercle autour d'une tombe donc ça c'est
clairement une utilisation religieuse de
des fossiles d'oursins et puis bah on a
parlé tout à l'heure des égyptiens qui
ont déposé des fossiles dans les temples
et possiblement l'utilisation rituel
pour le rite de la fertilité associés
alors auxerre qui a été retrouvé il ya
trois cent mille ans par homo sapiens
archaïque à erfoud et en maintenant
yariv la question évidemment de mais
vraiment vraiment est-ce qu'il ya aucune
utilisation scientifique des fossiles
qui a été fait à l'époque précoloniale
en afrique ou ailleurs d'ailleurs bombe
à la réponse est voilà et c'est bien là
où il faut comprendre aussi les limites
de la démarche
on peut changer de point de vue mais on
ne peut pas changer l'histoire faut une
fois de plus
et j'insiste là dessus réécrire
l'histoire
c'est une démarche malhonnête changer de
point de vue sur l'histoire c'est une
démarche qui a du mérite
mais il ya des étapes de l'histoire
qu'on ne peut pas changer et notamment
la naissance de la paléontologie telle
qu'on la pratique aujourd'hui telle
qu'on la pratique en tant que science
elle a des racines profondément
occidentale et on peut pas lui enlever
on peut pas lui enlever ce à quoi donc
on ne rendra pas la science
paléontologique africaine c'est georges
cuvier c'est charles darwin s'est elle
cite d'orbigny bref voilà on n'aura pas
de vous vous aurez beau retourner le
problème dans tous les sens il y aura
aucun moyen de de rendre la science
paléontologique africaine par contre on
peut quand même saluer certains certains
éléments me certaines certains
événements et notamment ibn khaldoun un
savant médiévale
l'époque médiévale de tunisie qui 500
ans avant la naissance de charles darwin
parlait déjà quand même de l'homme
descend du singe
vous voyez que même si on ne peut pas
dire que la science de l'évolution et de
la paléontologie sont nés en afrique ou
ailleurs que de toute façon sont pas nés
ailleurs que dans le monde occidental
on a quand même l'idée qu' il ya une île
que comment dire à partir du moment où
on se met à réfléchir à la question êtes
vous aviez des grands philosophes à
l'époque médiévale dans le moyen-orient
et en afrique du nord donc dans le monde
musulman
vous aviez des grands philosophes grande
élite intellectuelle qui a réfléchi
quand même à la question et j'avais fait
tout un épisode là dessus avec mon ami
abdou mon ami et collègue abdou on avait
fait tout un épisode là dessus où
justement on discutait d'un de ces
savants qui s'était quand même presser
le citron et étaient quand même venus à
des conclusions qui sont diablement
similaire à celle que les savants du
futur pour eux c'était des savants du
futur les savants du futur en occident à
les conduire qui allait conduire à
l'élaboration de la théorie de
l'évolution
et ça ça veut dire une chose très simple
ça veut dire que quoiqu'il quel que soit
votre background culturel géographique
ou historique ou voix à partir du moment
où vous commencez à vous poser la
question de l'origine des espèces bas et
notamment de l'origine humaine et ben ça
devient difficile de conclure autre
chose que l'homme descend du singe et
donc il viendra donner l'un de ces
exemples et c'est un exemple africains
donc j'aime le site et dans le cadre de
secours il y en a d'autres bien sûr il y
en a d'autres il n'y a pas que ibn
khaldoun
il ya en italie notamment je ne sais
plus son nom j'en avais parlé dans la
vidéo dans une autre vidéo j'en avais
parlé il ya un italien qui tout début de
la renaissance parler aussi de l'homme
descend du singe
bref l'homme qui descend du singe si on
fouille même
alors si on fouille et qu'on lit entre
les lignes je crois même qu'on arrive à
retrouver sa dans la
grèce antique mais faut vraiment lire
entre les lignes faut vraiment arriver à
trouver le passage de la ligne est
vraiment arrivé à le déchiffrer
vous avez fait un peu de contorsions
intellectuelles pour en tirer du jus
mais il y en a qui disent même que à
l'époque de la grèce antique on aurait
pu on aurait pu déjà balancé un truc du
genre l'homme descend du singe
personnellement je suis pas convaincu
personnellement je suis pas hyper
convaincu mais en tout cas voilà c'est à
partir du moment où on se creuse le
citron on arrive assez rapidement à la
conclusion que l'homme et le singe
c'est assez proche donc et ibn khaldoun
la formule et d'une façon très claire
d'ailleurs steve jobs mais les rythmes
de world of monkeys
voilà donc le stade plus élevé de
l'homme donc évidemment on a une pensée
en stade évolutif pas encore la belle
pas encore le béa l'arbre phylogénétique
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui mes pensées en
stade évolutif et donc le stade plus
élevé de l'homme est atteint à partir de
celui du singe avait-il atteint cette
conclusion à partir des preuves
paléontologique la réponse est non
puisque il parle ensuite que c'est la
sagacité la perception et la réflexion
la réflexion et la pensée humaine émerge
de ce qu'on voit déjà chez le singe donc
en fait c'est une observation qui est
faite surtout à partir du comportement
des sages est pas tellement de leur
anatomie ou même du registre fossile
donc on n'est pas encore sûr une
utilisation scientifique de la
paléontologie avec ibn khaldoun ça
n'arrivera façon ça arrivera qu'avec
oxley quand il commencera à parler
justement de la paléontologie de l'homme
ça n'arrivera qu'avec les découvertes de
néandertal dans les années 1800 bref
c'est pas pour tout de suite
c'est pas pour tout de suite et donc non
il n'y a pas de paléontologie
scientifiques en afrique avant l'arrivée
2 des scientifiques des scientifiques et
de l'époque coloniale bon et donc ça
c'est ce que je vous disais c'est
évidemment la théorie de l'évolution du
coup ça vous montre qu'elle n'a pas de
religion de pas de race pas de politique
et pas de limites culturel c'est juste
à partir du moment où on se creuse le
citron sur l'origine des espèces on
finit toujours par tomber sur la même
conclusion
c'est ça la science c'est la
répétabilité des observations donc
maintenant qu'on a bien établi
tout ça c'est l'heure de conclure bien
tant qu'on a maintenant qu'on a bien
établi qu'en changeant un peu de
perspectives on arrive à montrer que les
êtres humains sont capables de collecter
des fossiles depuis très longtemps y
compris depuis l'époque coloniale et
était déjà capable de se dire que les
fossiles
ça valait quelque chose de plus que les
cailloux normaux bah ça nous amène
plusieurs conséquences on va dire sur
notre façon de penser l'évolution
humaine et de penser notre façon de
l'enseigner la théorie de l'évolution
donc la première c'est déjà bassil et si
les gens étaient capables de collecter
des fossiles depuis trois cents mille
ans et qu'ils étaient capables de capter
ce petit je ne sais quoi qui adore les
fossiles et donc ça des applications sur
l'évolution de la cognition humaine il
ya déjà trois cent mille ans les gens
étaient capables de reconnaître les faux
cils pour ce qui est pour quelques comme
étant quelque chose de spécial pâques en
mettant pas pour ce qu'ils sont mais en
tout cas comme étant quelque chose de
spécial et ça ça veut dire que dans leur
cerveau et basse a mijoté et passe à
mijoter
et du coup c'est intéressant a remarqué
dans le cadre de notre compréhension de
l'évolution de l'intelligence humaine
deuxièmement c'est marrant parce que
j'ai corrigé de cent millions 300 mille
entre de diapos c'est pas grave
deuxièmement ça peut mener à une
nouvelle interprétation justement 2d des
peintures pariétales qu'on trouve
notamment à côté d'autres fossiles
donc on a par exemple ici une figure qui
a été gravé sur un caillou par les
bushmen fou sur une roche par des
bushmen et on ça représente on dirait
une espèce de machin enroulée en fait
sur lui un animal segmenté en rouler ça
ressemble quand même furieusement à
notre trilobites deflate place donc pour
l'instant on n'est pas trop capable
d'interpréter ça alors peut-être que
c'est juste un mille-pattes enroulé sur
lui-même mais bon peut-être que ça aussi
à voir avec certains fossiles que c'est
bushmen ont pu collecter et ici bas on a
des peintures pariétales
ici des peintures pariétales lalala il
yad'autres l'est y en a d'autres ses
peintures pariétales elles ont été
faites sur un mur où il faut
littéralement marché sur des empreintes
de dinosaures pour y accéder enfin
l'occurrence ramper parce que c'est un
tout petit c'est un tout petit mur en
fait c'est pas bien où tout ça donc il
faut ramper sur des empreintes de
dinosaures pour pouvoir accéder à cette
paroisse il est impossible que les gens
qui n'ont pas cette paroisse n'ai pas vu
les empreintes de dinosaures
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
les deux ont à voir les uns avec les
autres
ce serait intéressant d'aller voir du
côté justement déco occurrence entre les
empreintes de dinosaures et les parois
est ce que les parois ont toujours été
choisi au pif ou choisis pour leur
intérêt esthétique ou leur accessibilité
ou bien est ce que le fait qu'ils aient
des fossiles associés à ces parois a
joué un rôle dans le choix de ses parois
point d'interrogation on ne le sait pas
mais ce sera intéressant à voir et j'ai
des corrigés la faute sur le 300 milles
donc évidemment la bonne date ici c'est
300 milles 1 évidemment c'est pas 200
milles et du coup pour nous
paléontologues qu'est ce que ça change
pas ça change que il faut arrêter de
partir du principe que les gens ne
savent rien des fossiles c'est pas parce
que les gens ne comprennent pas les
communautés locales c'est comme ça qu'on
les appelle en afrique du sud les
communautés locales
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'éducation paléontologique qu'il ne
savait rien des fossiles il faut
interagir avec eux il faut leur demander
ce qu'ils savent il faut pour et ça ça
peut permettre à la découverte de
nouveaux sites
ça a permis la découverte de nouveaux
sites en chine par exemple en chine ils
ont interrogé les gens pour leur
demander ce qu'ils savaient des fossiles
en chine en plus ils ont une énorme
tradition de de collecte de fossiles bas
en chine vous avez des endroits vous à
moi de vous avez une colline qui
s'appelle littéralement la colline des
autres dragons et quand vous savez que
les autres dragons sont systématiquement
des ossements fossiles
ben évidemment que quand vous arrivez
dans un endroit et que l'on vous dit bah
la colline là bas ça s'appelle la
colline des autres dragons tu fais ah
ouais bah on va aller voir
du coup
voilà donc vous demandez vous demandez
aux gens des laves aux autres dragons
ils viennent de houba ils viennent de
là-bas attendez il ya peut-être un bon
gros sites paléontologiques là bas du
cou donc en chine c'est assez évident
comment on peut arriver à ça en afrique
ça l'est beaucoup moins
déjà parce que comme je le dis il n'y a
pas d' utilisation médicinale des
fossiles donc la tradition de
connaissance des fossiles elle n'est pas
si prononcée que ça mais vous avez des
sites comme ça qui sont connus
populairement de la connaissance popul
il ya une connaissance populaire des
fossiles
c'est juste qu'il n'appelle pas ça des
fossiles et du coup chose engagé les
populations locales pour savoir
justement ben qu'est-ce qu'il ya de quoi
il en retourne de quoi il en faut
engager la conversation avec eux et il
ya des fois où ça ça a payé donc là par
exemple c'est l'extrait je vous ai mis
un petit extrait d'une thèse de master
enfin d'une dissertation de master où
justement la personne a découvert un
nouveau site avec des feuilles fossiles
voiliers de très très belles feuilles
fossiles qui était connue d'une des
élèves d'une école depuis plusieurs
décennies
depuis plusieurs décennies connaissait
le site et les paléontologues d'un seul
coup ils sont arrivés ils ont dit mettez
ça fait combien de temps que c'est là ça
plusieurs décennies donc non ça arrivent
épuisés et le monde occidental n'est pas
à l'abri de ça non plus
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure il
ya des empreintes de dinosaures qui
était connue depuis super longtemps
comme étant les empreintes du corbeau de
noé
voilà bah oui mais on vous dit les
empreintes du corbeau de nous et vous
parle pas mais oui mais si vous n'allez
pas plus loin que ça
eh ben vous passez à côté de la
découverte d'empreintes de pas de
dinosaures
donc ça c'est aussi une autre façon
encore une fois ce changement de
perspective c'est aussi une autre façon
d'envisager la paléontologie
c'est à dire lever les yeux de la carte
géologique pour demander aux gens ce
qu'ils savent
voilà c'est c'est aussi ça la
paléontologie du mois c'est une autre
façon d'envisager la paléontologie
voilà donc je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi ce cours et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
une nouvelle session de ces de ce fil
rouge de l'été salut